moscú aplicará una serie de
restricciones para contener al cob y 19
a partir del lunes 25 de octubre de los
mayores de 60 años no vacunados deberán
trabajar en sus hogares y los
trabajadores de servicio tendrán que
estar vacunados se prevé que estas
restricciones duren hasta finales de
febrero de 2022
la medida llega luego de que el
miércoles se registrará la mayor cifra
de muertes porque hoy 19 desde la
llegada del virus al país con 1.028
fallecimientos
dada la situación actual ciertamente
respaldó queridos colegas del gabinete
la propuesta de declarar los días no
laborales con sueldo completo desde el
30 de octubre de 2021 hasta el 7 de
noviembre de 2021 inclusive en todo el
país 9 miembros kuchiki el aumento de
las muertes y los contagios se deben a
un escepticismo de las vacunas sólo el
32 por ciento de la población ha sido
inmunizada a pesar de la disponibilidad
de su vacuna sputnik ve el número total
de muertos en rusia asciende a más de
225.000 el mayor en europa la
organización mundial de la salud afirma
que este aumento en europa representa el
7 por ciento de los nuevos casos de
coronavirus en el mundo
está muy claro que los países que tienen
una menor aceptación de las vacunas es
donde estamos viendo los efectos graves
de la pandemia en este momento en
términos de muertes y personas que
terminan en el hospital por lo tanto en
ese sentido
ya tiene un 30 por ciento de su
población completamente vacunado desde
el inicio de la pandemia rusia ha
registrado más de 7 millones 969 mil
casos de coronavirus lo que lo convierte
en el quinto del mundo después de eeuu
india brasil y el reino unido-